hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and we are here at the
collider supper suite at tiff uh and i
am so thrilled to be with the stars of
bros um i really want to start with a
sincere congratulations uh i thought
your movie was fantastic and it i've
seen a lot of films at tiff already and
uh yours was one of my favorites thank
you thank you very much i i really want
to say um congrats like i said but
mostly i really want to give a huge
thank you to universal pictures yeah for
making this movie and can you sort of
talk a little bit about the fact that
they they put the money up to tell this
story
they did they put the money up
they paid for us to be sitting here
right now
um no they've been incredible
partners collaborators uh i
i give so much credit to them i have so
much gratitude for
not only making the movie but how they
approached it you know allowing us not
only allowing us supporting the idea of
casting all openly lgbtq actors and
supporting the idea that we would tell
an authentic story you know that we
weren't coating anything that we wanted
to make it hilarious but we also wanted
to make it very honest and i can't thank
them enough they really have been so
supportive you know i lived in fear for
many years of getting calls like oh the
script is
too gay or too edgy or to this or to
that those calls never arrived they
always were very supportive and it's
been amazing and treating it like a real
movie all the way to this point you know
they're not they're not sort of putting
it sort of on the shelf and saying it'll
do its thing it'll find its audience
they really are supporting us yeah yeah
i definitely want to know um obviously
it is imperative that your relationship
in the film works um and i'm just
curious what was it like doing those
chemistry reads figuring out who's going
to be playing opposite you um and what
that whole process was like also for you
you know auditioning for the movie yeah
totally i mean it was that rare
experience of reading the script and
immediately connecting with it just
understanding this guy i knew billy i've
been a big fan of his we had never
actually met personally um so stepping
into that room the first time i
i felt like i understood the guy and i
understood who aaron was but i really
really really wanted to impress him and
um
it was nice when we kind of hit it off
in the room it was very nice yeah
um luke and i just i don't it's hard to
explain chemistry you know we didn't
know each other i do think that helped
in a way um because we got to discover
each other as our characters were
discovering each other
um and i don't know you know we're very
similar in certain ways we're very
different in certain ways
i think we have a lot of respect for
each other but also
i don't know like intimidate each other
a little bit like we make each other a
little nervous partially because we
didn't really know each other um i don't
know it just worked for some reason i
it's hard to explain why now that we
know each other we have zero chemistry
zero
[Laughter]
one of the things i found fascinating
was that you guys made this film i
believe in 34 days um and my
i think it was something like that right
which is for people that don't realize
that's not a lot of time yeah so did you
can you sort of talk about filming it
you know on a schedule like that and did
you ever feel that pressure or was nick
always you know you never really
realized it
nick is truly incredible on set
especially
even under what would be very stressful
circumstances and even when there's so
much footage to get every single day
when the schedule is a bit more
compressed than you would ideally like
it to be
he always
somehow manages manages to establish
such a calm environment you know so
even though you know a lot needs to get
done you're never really feeling
stressed like that that's really like
something i appreciate about him so much
as an actor we obviously wrote the movie
together but then once you're on set
he's a director and i'm an actor you
know and i need his support and
encouragement and i need to make him you
know he needs to make me feel like
everything's gonna be okay even in spite
of all the chaos and he really does a
remarkable job doing that yeah truly and
especially in comedy because nothing
kills a joke more than someone like
screaming like we're gonna lose the
light so he yeah he really did keep it
calm i mean no matter how tight our
schedule was if me or any of the other
actors had a bit or a joke they wanted
to try he always made sure there was
time for that
um one of the things that i found it
just it feels very natural what happens
in the movie it feels it's based on
authenticity and can you sort of talk
about maybe some of the examples of
your real life permeating into this
movie
my real life permeates into the movie in
many ways um
experiences i've had with guys
experiences close friends of mine have
had
um in romantic relationships or with sex
love dating all of it
um
experiences i've had in my professional
life
um
there's so much of me in there even
though it's not identical to me
um but
you know i i really liked the idea one
of the first ideas we started with is
the idea that a very confident
self-reliant man
or person you know um
could be undone by falling in love like
someone who really prides himself on not
needing someone both characters do that
actually and i thought what happens when
two people like that fall for each other
like how do they navigate that and i
thought there was potential for a lot of
comedy in that and also a lot of
like you know poignant moments and
romantic moments and and that was the
idea i started with that i did borrow
from my real life that i i thought could
be compelling
one of the things i love learning about
um when you're making any movie or show
is like the behind the scenes things
that people wouldn't really realize so
what do you think soon to be fans of
bros would be surprised to learn about
the actual making of the movie
um new jersey for new york
let's not give everything away luke
um i think you'd be surprised that we
shot you know it's amazing because even
though we only shot in 34 days we had so
we had a very very long script
and there were some really big set
pieces which were very funny but
ultimately got cut from the movie um and
i think that might be interesting you
know and maybe they'll end up online or
something but we had some really funny
things that just got cut because
ultimately we some of the things were
very funny but very silly and absurd
and ultimately we wanted something that
felt grounded and honest and real for
the most part while also being very
funny so i always find that fascinating
i i also think and i i don't think i'm
giving too much away the musical number
was
was added during filming
so that was not part of the original
script that we started the shootout with
and yeah billy pushed for it or kind of
invented it it just kind of happened
very organically um but i don't want to
give too much of it
i don't want to give so much love luke's
giving everything away
you know something i i assure you that
um there's going to be enough buzz on
this that even if people hear specifics
they're going to want to experience it
can you sort of talk about um i think
that over the last few years there's
been a lot more representation in
hollywood i really feel like the
industry has taken big steps over the
last five or ten years definitely what
what are you
what do you guys think about that and do
you think that this is because this is
like a watershed moment in hollywood
making this movie releasing this movie
can you sort of talk about that aspect
and do you think this is the beginning
of another
chapter if you know what i mean
i hope so i mean bros is not operating
in a vacuum obviously we're part of this
wave of lgbtq content that we're seeing
on streaming and online um this is
one of very few major studio examples of
a movie like this and i think it's just
evidence that the industry finally is
evolving um and one thing i'm very proud
of in the movie is that you know
historically
straight actors have gotten to play the
vast majority of high-profile lgbtq
roles and we flipped the script in this
movie where openly lgbtq actors not only
get to play the lgbtq roles but also
there's all the straight roles in the
movie and you know no one wants to make
any strict rules about acting or art or
who should play what but
it's just odd there's been a real
imbalance historically about which
actors have gotten what types of
opportunities so
i think it's cool that you know we're
getting to tell our story we're getting
to control the narrative we're getting
to portray ourselves and really you know
fully encompass every aspect of this
major studio comedy in a way that we
haven't seen very much of before and if
i can say
hopefully
that that translates into seats in the
theater and money in the box office
because that's ultimately what it's
about it's trusting that there is a
space that will generate income for the
studios like let's be honest and and i
think we're starting to see that there
is and they can be confident in that and
i just want to see that become more and
more and more for sure we literally just
before the camera started rolling we're
talking about how the woman king is
coming out right that's a direct result
of black panther's success exactly and
that's why i'm so rooting for this movie
to be successful because this will open
the door just if it's financially viable
for so many other stories you know um uh
i'm thinking about some of my last
questions because i'm just about out of
time uh
i guess talk a little bit about before
filming began you obviously saw how many
pages of the script you had how many
scenes how much everything which is the
scene the night before filming that you
were the most in your head either
because it's a big sex scene it's crazy
dialogue or a monologue you have to
deliver and you know you're only gonna
get a few takes like what was that night
before
before our first day of shooting yeah i
said to nick stoller i only have two
requests right because planning a
shooting schedule can be hard it's based
on location and what actors are
available when and that's all very
complicated but i said i'll do anything
but i have two requests
i have a big scene in the middle of the
movie this monologue where i reveal a
lot to luke's character
um i said please don't have me do that
on the first day of shooting
and also don't have me do any intense
sex scenes with luke on the first day of
shooting and i did both
day of shooting i can't believe that
that was the first day of shooting yeah
literally yeah literally and nick was
like i'm really sorry the way like
locations work and everything we have to
do these on the first day and
that was something i really had to like
wrap my head around
but um you know i'm proud of how it all
came out do you think he oh maybe put
that on the schedule just to sort of
relay your fears and say you have to
just dive in deep on the first day or it
was just no i think it was literally
logistics i wish it was that poetic and
artistic um but i think it was just like
no there's this house we really want to
shoot it and they'll only let us shoot
there on our first day of shooting so
prepare yourself yeah yeah i i i exactly
i remember shooting that scene and you
know the first day of shooting you're
like learning everybody's name you still
don't know the dp's name you still don't
know the people that are doing your hair
and stuff and i'm lying there listening
to this monologue and going like what
movie are we making because you're also
having that conversation in your head
you're like what is this thing we're
making and this
monologue
i think is the heart of the movie in so
many ways so
yeah
yeah we really had to dive in uh on that
note i know
we're short on time today i just want to
say a sincere congratulations and how
much i really do hope this is a huge hit
for you guys and i hope a ton of people
watch if you're watching this interview
definitely seek this film out september
30th theater's everywhere yeah thank you
so much for stopping by our studio thank
you so much
you